We will now develop the
solution to the linear least
mean squares estimation problem.
We want to find
coefficients a and b
that make this expression,
this mean squared error,
as small as possible.
We will approach this problem
by proceeding in two stages.
In the first stage, we
assume that the choice of a
has already been
found and concentrate
on the question of choosing b.
Now if a has been
found and has been
fixed to a specific
number, then this quantity
here is a specific
random variable.
And what do we have?
We have a random variable
minus a constant.
And we want to
choose that constant,
so that this difference
squared is as small as possible
in the expected value sense.
So essentially, we're trying
to choose a constant b that
estimates this random variable
in the best possible way.
But this is a problem
that's familiar to us,
and we know that
the best choice of b
is equal to the expected
value of that random variable.
And using also linearity,
this expected value
can be written in this form.
So if we know a, this is
how b should be chosen.
Let us now move on
to the choice of a.
Since we know what b
should be equal to,
we can rewrite this
expression that we're
trying to minimize by
substituting our choice of b,
which is the expected
value of Theta minus aX.
And this is the quantity
we want to minimize.
What is it?
We have a random variable
minus the expected value
of that random variable squared.
And then we take expected value.
This is just the variance of the
random variable Theta minus aX.
This is the variance
of the difference
of two random variables.
Because the two random
variables are dependent,
this is not just the sum of
the individual variances.
But we do have a formula,
even for the general case.
And the formula tells
us that the variance
of the difference of
two random variables
is the variance of the
first random variable
plus the variance of the second.
And when we pull a
outside the variance,
that gives us a
contribution of a squared.
And then we have a cross-term.
Because of the minus
sign here, the cross-term
will have a minus sign.
We have a factor of 2.
And then we want the
covariance of Theta with aX.
And because we have seen
that covariances behave
in a linear manner, we can
pull a outside the covariance.
And this is what
we are left with.
This is the quantity we want
to optimize with respect to a.
And to do this
optimization, we just
set the derivative
with respect to a to 0.
And that's going to give us
2a times the variance of X
minus twice the covariance
of Theta with X, equal to 0.
From which it
follows that a should
be equal to the
covariance of Theta
with X divided by
the variance of X.
So we have found
what a should be.
Once we know what a is, we
know what b should be equal to.
So we have solved the problem.
And here's the form
of the solution.
This coefficient here
is the coefficient a.
So we have here the term aX.
And then this term together
with a times the expected value
of X, this corresponds
to the coefficient b.
It's also instructive
to rewrite this solution
in a slightly different form
involving the correlation
coefficient.
Recall that the correlation
coefficient between two
random variables is defined as
the covariance between the two
random variables
divided by the product
of their standard deviations.
Using this relation, we can
now write the coefficient a
as the covariance which is
who times sigma Theta sigma
X divided by the variance of
X, which is sigma X squared.
And after we cancel a factor
of sigma X from the numerator
and the denominator,
we see that a is also
equal to rho times sigma
Theta divided by sigma X.
And this gives us
this alternative form
for the solution.
What we will be doing next will
be to interpret this solution
and also to give a
number of examples.